um how i found out i'm transracial right
um i thought this was real this turned
out i got trolled but i want you to
watch because i want to give props
uh generation z coming up is kind of
funny check this
out this girl made this video and uh how
i found out i was transracial
hey guys probably tell from the title of
this video
i am going to be telling you how i found
out i was transracial
but before we get into that i'm going to
tell you what it means to be transracial
now many of you might be saying
being transgender you have to have
dysphoria to be transracial you have to
have
dystracia this ratio is where you don't
feel like really the race you are
that's how it was with me not many of
you know this but i
actually transitioned from plain
caucasian
to latina african caucasian
mix i felt uncomfortable in my own body
when filling out forms that say what's
your race
i just didn't want to put caucasian and
when i clicked that
i could be so much more then i found the
trans-racial community and i just felt
so safe there without further ado this
is how i found out i
was trans racial stop hitting the mic
so the first one is using the built-in
headphone mic oh that's horrible
doubt that i was actually transracial is
that i used to wake up in the morning
and realize that i didn't want to go to
starbucks anymore
and i didn't want to sleep on my uggs
and i didn't want to go to the gym
i didn't want to go with my yoga workout
group
any longer i was like what's this change
in me it's like
wait so
those are like the first signs of me not
being she just go to the dentist that's
just how she talks because she's one of
the
crookedest most dry mouths i've got it's
like a mouthful of cotton
let's check it anymore ever since then
i've eaten a lot of talkies and if i
like see somebody i know i'll be like
hola
like it just comes out i wouldn't have
to think about it it just was like
something that would happen that's how i
realized i was part latina
then the way i figured out that i was
actually african-american was i was
meeting up with my friends
and like i was like hey my and then the
video ends
one minute and 49 set up for that joke
one minute and 49 seconds set up who is
that
chick uh her name is plubus
and look look at the description look at
the description it just says n-word
i like this check you're in it i'll post
a link in the chat
i'm all in with you
asmr abortion clinic no she does swear
no she doesn't no she doesn't i think i
like this chick now
okay you know what i'm all on board with
this product
guys as you can probably most likely
tell from the title
i am doing an asmr abortion clinic
so um let's not waste any time because
that is stupid
and let's get right into the video i
just gotta stop with that mike
hello welcome
is this your first time
that's wonderful this is awesome
all the fetuses get donated to
mcdonald's
okay you know what i'm all in with this
chick now hold on
subscribe oh my god this chick is the
best
she's amazing okay well we have a new
friend we gotta make friends this is
hilarious would you like someone's gonna
drink
it okay
[Music]
[Laughter]
how old is your baby okay
so uh are you sure you want to do this
by the way said in in no planned
parenthood ever no of course not
okay we'll get started so
make sure you just fill out that content
form right there because
we don't want any lawsuits you know
anyways
um so once you fill it out i will go get
your pill
that will get the baby out of you um
a beautiful process i like probably
avoided like
47. this chick is based
i like her she's hilarious she's
anti-gun control
i'm i like this chick yeah she is you're
uh
you're she's a good egg she is a keeper
pl plubus she's a video called why
nicholas cruz is so attractive i love
this check
yes hey guys plebus here today i'm going
to be
discussing why nicholas cruz is actually
innocent
and why he is the cutest person ever
oh i love this chick you oh you [ __ ]
get it
this is amazing she [ __ ] statcha
gets it man this is holy this is a rare
one a whole really funny one [ __ ]
wow because of his hair and i really
like his hair because it's so flowy
and he has a really get out of here
holy [ __ ] she's amazing
oh [ __ ] oh my god that is amazing yeah
good good work wow
here i just posted the [ __ ] link
i just posted it twice
there you go well the shooting that he
did which killed dozens of innocent kids
wasn't even a big deal like their
parents could have just easily gone over
that
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
wasn't even a big deal like
their parents could have just easily
gone over that like it's just a death of
your child
like he's innocent because the kid
because
they were bullying him and which was a
really hard time for nicholas cruz
i hope you guys can't do this this
is indeed innocent and that you will
fight for his rights
great man she's funny man [ __ ]
generation zygote i told you when i
first saw it i was gonna i thought i was
gonna get mad
because what i saw was oh great trans
racial good now we have to deal with
this dummy
but man she is very very keeper there
man that's
like everybody give her a little